up until the book heretics of doing the
most powerful weapons that we knew of in
the new universe were the atomic weapons
that the Great Houses of the landsraad
had agreed to reserve just in case human
beings ever needed to face off against a
nonhuman threat but when other humans
came returning from deep within the
cosmos this all changed
[Music]
this video will contain spoilers for the
entire dune saga sometime after the year
15 200 AG the planet Arrakis home of the
great worms the first source of the
spice melange was hit by the weapon the
device which was given the name
obliterators in sandworms and hunters of
doon was brought into the old empire by
the honored montrezl sisterhood who had
come out of the scattering seeking bene
Jesuit secrets the honored MA trace had
hoped to destroy the many Jesuits
sources spice by unleashing the power of
the weapon upon doom and eliminating the
sandworms the matras had also been
enraged that the bene Jesuit Bashara
miles tag had done harm to them
previously they intended to destroy him
as well the honored mater a succeeded in
destroying miles tag for the moment that
was but they did not succeed in
destroying the bene Jesuit sisterhood
source of spice but it was not because
of the weapons lack of power the bene
Jesuit managed to escape with one worm
before the power of the weapon was
unleashed the surface of the planet
Arrakis was scorched when the mot rays
fired their missiles at dune the
atmosphere of the world ignited
beginning to evaporate rapidly all life
on the planet was annihilated the sand
of rack is melted by the intense heat
caused by massive fireballs amalgamated
into a structure of hard glass the bene
Jesuit barely saved their worm but the
montrezl intended to use their weapon
again very little is revealed about the
origin and the true nature of the weapon
in the original saga it is not until the
expanded dune books by Brian Herbert and
Kevin J Anderson that we learned more
during their time in the scattering the
honored mater a sisterhood stumbled upon
a remote outpost created by Thinking
Machines these were the remnants of the
Machine Empire which had not been fully
destroyed during the but Larry
jihad they stole the obliterators from
there and destroyed the outpost which
alerted the larger whole of the Machine
Empire the MOT Reyes did not realize
that the machines possessed an even
greater weapon as retribution the
machines unleashed the scourge a deadly
plague in Frank Herbert's book god
emperor of doom there is a reference to
seeking machines who would hunt and kill
humans it seems to refer to an exceed
invention but I suppose that you could
potentially interpret it so that it
could refer to the machine empire that
appears in the expanded books in the
book chapter house dune it is also
mentioned that the honored mantra is
feared a biological weapon from the
scattering which had quote made
vegetables of them this would explain
why the matras came back to the old
Empire seeking Binnie Jesuit secrets the
bene Jesuit could control their internal
chemistry on a cellular level and it
likely would have been able to resist
the scourge personally I've always been
terrified by the thought of a biological
weapon it's not even something that's
that far removed from reality at this
very moment it is theoretically possible
to engineer a super virus a world's
scorching device is also quite
terrifying though in my opinion not
quite as much as the idea of the scourge
the obliterator device had limited power
and in a universe where humans have
inhabited mini worlds losing one while
terrible would not be the end-all be-all
but with the virus once it's Unleashed
it would be near impossible to deal with
sure the bene Jesuit could resist it but
most humans could not the only hope
would be for infected world's to cut off
contact with all other worlds
effectively leading to a Dark Age thank
you guys so much for watching make sure
you like and subscribe for more ideas of
Ice and Fire
I am super excited to announce that I've
been working on a graphic novel slash
comic book Todd yeah if you want to
learn more about this series click the
link in the description to get put on my
email list and I will keep you guys
updated as the development of this
project continues I've been working with
Mike Miller who is where
with Georgia Martin in the past and
image comments and a bunch of other
comic publishers and I'm just super
excited to share with you guys this
story that I've created about mythology
and stories and magic
[Music]